Thank you all for being here today.
Building net new applications
or modernizing legacy
applications using
event-based architecture is an effective
way to modernize your applications
using events
and asynchronous behavior to achieve scalability.
What happens though when the business
events and characteristics dictate
that that's not enough?
That's Martin and I'm Jeff, and
over the next hour, we're gonna
introduce where and how.
To include
AI and agents into your event-based
architecture to meet those needs of your business.
First
we're gonna set up the scenario that we have here at our
at our company, the Unicorn Gaming Shop.
We're gonna play a couple roles here.
Apologize that the cartoons don't look exactly
like us, but this is what licensing provided us.
Thank you, thank you, Jeff.
So my name is Marin. Welcome in
my name also.
So I am an application product owner. I'm
new to this company.
I have 20 plus years of experience
in doing these things.
Basically this company, I am tasked
to define new features to to drive
the greater customer satisfaction. The main
thing is we want to expand
and we want to try to automate as much as
possible.
Our customer interaction on one side,
but we also want to help our engineers
in the back end when we have an issue with the
application. Any type of issue
to help them out and to speed up the
process when they need to resolve some issues. Also,
we want to automate
part of the resolution process
so the only most important and most hard
things come to our backend
engineers which will then step in
and resolve the issue. We want to lower that
response time
for our
troubleshooting process.
And I'm Jeff.
I'm an experienced software developer and I've been working
at Unicorn Game Shop for quite some
time. I've been modernizing that
application over the years using
event-driven architecture and Event bridge,
and I'm tasked with maintaining and building the
new features that Martin's coming up
with for the Game Shop application that we
have. And of
course, I do have lots of new features.
I'm new here. I need to prove myself,
and I definitely have some big, big
ideas for this company. We need to expand.
We need to expand to increase our customer base.
Really
great ideas, Martin.
I'd like to hear some of these things.
You may not like some of them
because they are really big ideas. So basically
I signed 10 new deals for
our company and that will drive actually
50 times user growth than what we have now.
So I think
you have your plate full for this one, Jeff.
Did you say
10?
And 50 times more growth exactly.
Thank you.
Please. That's
quite a task that he set me up for.
Some of the things that I'm immediately thinking about when I have
to deal with that
is
the scale that that's gonna cause
in terms of the overload
to the team that I have.
How about having the operational visibility
about everything that's happening across this
dynamically scaling and growing system.
I'd like to use AI but I got limited experience
with that both myself and my team,
and I got limited,
limited team, limited time,
limited budget.
Now, I mentioned before that I've
been modernizing this application that we have here
usingvent driven architecture and EventBridge,
and EventBridge is the core of what our architecture
is right now that I have in the system.
And EventBridge really is providing
me 3 things 1,
It takes in the events that are
coming from any one of the producers that we have here.
In this case, it's my application.
And then I have a bus, and I can have 3
different kinds of kinds of buses. I can have the default bus,
which integrates with the APIs
of AWS services, the
custom event bus which I'm using to handle the
particular events that we have in our system,
or the SASS event bus,
and then the rules is the third part of this, and
the rules dictate what happens with the event
that comes in and where does it, where does it go to.
Now I've been coupling that with
using the leave-in layer architecture
pattern.
The leave-in layer architecture pattern is
where I have a legacy system up
here and I'm building net new capability
in that system
off to the side of it.
I'm building that
using
event bridge here to handle particular
transactions that I have here that were business features
that Martin came up with before,
which is
introducing
an event-based chat capability to our
customer assistants who could answer
questions asynchronously with
customers that we have
who are purchasers of games through our unicorn
game shop.
And it works well,
but I'm concerned about how that's gonna scale
with the amount of growth that we're gonna be having here
based upon what Martin's telling me with 50
times more users,
that's gonna be overwhelming to our customer
service assistant.
And how am I going to maintain the operational
observability and everything that's going on
with all those logs are getting produced by all these
new things that are happening.
I could use my system as it
is right now,
technically it'll work,
it's serverless, it's event based,
all the messages flowing through there are asynchronous,
however,
it only scales to the customer
assistant.
The customer assistant has to do
the research to answer the questions
that come in
from the customer.
And it's slow. It's slow
because the customer assistant is doing a lot
of work here
and they're going to get overwhelmed.
I've been doing a lot of research,
and I've learned
that I can introduce AI to help me out
here
and in the AWS world, AI really,
really comes in what we call
uh Amazon bedrock.
And Bedrock is our service that
provides API access
to both AWS
first party models as well as third
party models from the leading providers.
What I like about this is with this API layer
is I can integrate that into my system
without binding myself to any particular
model, and then I can.
Learn how my system is providing
the answers that I that I want to
my customer on the far end, and
I can change the models as I want over
time. I can also
fine tune my models to even get better
um quality in terms of the results
that I'm getting out there
so I'm really interested in how I'm gonna put this
into my system
to really start to drive the
results that I want
with the customer that I have.
So
I'm, I built.
A little chat that I can use, a
research assistant chat for my customer assistants.
My architecture is still serverless. It's
still event based. It's still asynchronous.
Now I have research augmentation
here through the integration of Bedrock in there for that
customer service, the customer assistance person,
and it is faster
than it was before.
However, it's still not fast,
and it still only scales to the
customer assistant.
In doing more research, I got
even more information about this
idea of agents.
And
what really intrigues me about the agents is
they are autonomous systems that can
understand requests,
make decisions, and act autonomously
to do tasks.
This sounds like a great way to
augment that customer assistant and scale
to the business that I have.
And when I think about the agents, they come in
a couple of different styles.
First, I can be thinking about agents that do
department level tasks, which are things that are
going to require data that's very near,
typically things that aren't going to be terribly complicated, and
maybe the security is not
that strong in that area.
Organization agent agents will work
across the boundaries of my systems, maybe
across the boundaries of my lines of business inside my company.
Usually greater access to data security is
going to start to become
a little bit more important here
in terms of who can access what
and then external agents,
which are going to be working outside the boundaries of
my application,
outside the boundaries of my company, interacting
with third party APIs and third party data.
I absolutely need a lot of control
in what's happening in there.
And as I think about this, I think about how am
I going to manage all of this
in this world and how am I going to run it.
And that's where Amazon
Bedrock Agent Corp comes in,
and it provides 3 things for me.
First,
it provides the tools and the memory
that my agent needs, and the memory
is really important
because a lot of times when you're doing prototyping with
with agents,
they're very short term memory, meaning you
give them a task, they do it, they forget about
it when they're done, you ask them a subsequent
question and they gotta go redo everything they did the first
time. With this, there's memory
built into this through agent course of that
agent, so when you ask subsequent
questions, they remember what was theirs
before and you can chain everything together.
Second, it provides the runtime
environment and the identity management
of the agent so that I can then
control who can
access that agent and what that agent is allowed
to do. This is important
to me because that agent that I have
is going to be producing recommendations,
is going to be interacting with a large
set of data, and is gonna be responding
back, uh, externally.
And third, the observability.
There's gonna be a lot going on in the system
as it scales, and it's gonna producing
a lot of decisions. I need to
have the observability not only
into the logs that it's getting that are getting
produced from the transactions that are happening here,
but I need to also be able to kind of audit and observe
how that agent made the decisions that it
did so that I can train the model
even further to make the decisions even
more in line with what I want going
forward. Now
as I think about bringing this all together
in my application, there's two
real patterns that I'm focusing on here
with my existing application
and how I would be integrating and incorporating
agents for the decision making that I wanna
have in here,
and this is where everything kind
of comes together with event bridge and the agent.
So first, the first pattern.
Event bridge triggering agents.
In this case,
events are coming in from any number of sources.
It could be S3. It could be a schedule. It could
be lambda. In my case, it's going to be
this web application that I have that has a chat
built into it.
The messages come through as event into
Event bridge, and Event bridge is going to.
Invoke
Bedrock to go do something in
the case that I have here it's going to be
go do some research
based upon what the customer is asking for and
provide back a recommendation
on what could serve the need of that
particular customer.
The second one
is agent triggered event based
agent triggered
event bridge events. This is kind of the opposite
of it. This starts by the agent
doing something,
doing some research, making a decision, looking
at something,
and then it producing an event
that gets put out onto event bridge that
can then work in a fan out kind of pattern
to say anyone who wants to do
something based upon this event can now go do
something based upon this event.
Together
These two patterns are going to help me greatly
in how I need to both handle the concerns
that I have around.
Producing this
game recommended
game recommendation feature that I wanna have from my customer
assistant. Which is really gonna be the
first pattern and then how am I gonna handle all
this operational observability that I
have
and maintaining kind of the the site reliability
with everything that's going to be going on in
my system.
So first,
agent powered game recommendation.
I have my system as it was
before and what I'm doing here
is I'm introducing
the agent that I built
which is going to act on the information
that it receives
from the event which is the chat that
the customer is having to say I'm
interested in new types of games I like these
kinds of things what would you recommend for me?
The agent is gonna get that and the agent
is gonna can do a couple things
first
before it even does the research.
You can ask the agent. You can have the agent work to
say determine the sentiment of this person
if they're positive or maybe they're neutral,
you probably don't need to have a lot of touch with them.
You can have the agent kind of offline handle
that themselves, but maybe the person's calling
to say your games stink.
I want my money back. I don't like what's going
on here.
Here you can have the agent make a decision and say, I
understand the sentiment. This person probably needs
to go talk to another person. I'm gonna route that
to my customer service
agent,
however. We build good games
and we think that's going to be a small amount of the transactions,
so. When the event comes
in, the agent can first determine
what's the sentiment, who should I be routing this to?
When it decides that it should be handling it,
it can go do that research,
gather the information, provide the recommendations
back out to my customer.
Now remember, because this is also
built using Agent Core, which has the first thing which I
said was the memory.
There can be a chain set of
conversation going back and forth here.
And the agent's gonna be consistently remembering
what was before and building all the responses
based upon what it knows
and not having to redo all that work that it
did the first time.
1, that saves time.
2, it saves money because
the agent's not incurring more
cycles
to go reproduce stuff that it already did analysis
on. So
This becomes a way that I can introduce that
first pattern, that event bridge,
event bridge triggering agents pattern
to solve for this problem that I have about building
and scaling
game recommendations for my customer.
That solves one of my problems.
My second problem is
site reliable engineering, so.
I have my system and it's all instrument
instrumented with cloud watch
and now that my scale's growing 50 times
I'm producing a lot, a lot, a
lot of logs
and my engineer
that I have, remember I got a limited team limited
budget, he's gonna become overwhelmed
with having to
understand what's happening in there and look for
things that need to be dug into
and where maybe something is trending bad,
something needs to be fixed, something needs to be
done. So
the cloud Watcher cloud Watch blogs are growing
exponentially.
As good as I build this system, guess what,
errors occur.
And sometimes they're minor, and sometimes
they're major.
Either way, they need to be looked at.
Here Using
cloud watch, I can set up cloud
watch alarms
based upon particular things that could be happening
erroneously in my system.
Based upon those cloud watch alarms,
when something goes into an alarm.
I can invoke
my agent. I can invoke my SRE agent.
That agent can do a couple
things.
First,
it's gonna be able to understand what's
happening with that particular alarm,
and it also understands the architecture of my
system and the implementation of that system
to say what could that possibly
be the root cause of.
It can then determine the severity
of that.
Hopefully, most of my issues are low severity
type, type of things, and it can be a quick fix kind
of thing, but some might be high severity.
And similar to what we had in the first pattern,
it can make the decision that I want
high severity ones
to get. Dropped as
an SNS message that my engineer
is gonna pick up, and hopefully there should be a
small amount of those things,
but for the ones that are low severity or medium medium
severity,
I want the agent to go fix it themselves,
and maybe I can build a little something there that when
I have that, the agent can go.
You know,
maybe redeploy some code for me somewhere
else. Maybe shut down a failing server.
It can do the things in my system that
my engineer used to have to do, but now they
can do it fully autonomously.
Now this thing can scale out
very large to that 50 times volume
I want
without overwhelming that engineer,
and it'll do it tirelessly and it'll
do it repetitively.
So here's how I can introduce that agent
triggered event bridge pattern
to solve for that problem.
That combination of the agents in the system
running on agent court that memory and the
run time have allowed me to both scale
to meet the need of the business that I have as
well as scale to that operational support
that I need to have,
and it's providing wonderful results. Now
it's great to hear about all this stuff,
but it's even better to see a demo on how this all gets
built. And with that,
I will hand it over to Martin
for the demo.
OK, I got it from the first time.
So
as Jeff explained,
And you can see this is a recording. There is a reason
why this is recording. We did not trust the
demo gods that it will everything work
on the stage, so
just to make it safe and
secure that it's actually going to run and show
everything we want to show,
we recorded the demo session. So I will go
through it. It's about 22 minutes
long, so please bear with me while
we go through this.
We will show two cases.
So as Jeff explained,
the first case will be helping our
customer agents
to help our customers
look for
similar games
that they want to play, to offer them some
similar games that they already played, and to enable
customers to interact with the
agents.
In this case, AI agent
that will give them some proposals, but
an additional layer on top of that
will be that they will be able to
provide a sentiment
or some kind of feeling.
Do they like something or don't they like
something, so the agent can then
based on that,
rephrase the proposal and give them maybe
a different list of
games to play with.
The 2nd 1, the 2nd demo,
which is a bit longer one because it has more components,
will be the one including our
engineer in the back end
where we will see mostly stuff
in the console and in the code
that supports our engineer to
resolve cases much more faster.
So the logic is again, as explained,
that we will have an alert triggered by a
fake lambda.
Trigger which will go then to EventBridge
and then that alert will follow
through Agent Corp which will
then go through
seek additional information about the problem
and then decide is that problem
low, medium, or high severity.
And based again on the sentiment
of the problem,
we'll send it either
to some outer mediation,
which can be restart the service,
start something, stop something, run a code or
whatever,
or if it decides it's a high
level
problem or issue,
send an email to the engineer to escalate
further into the case. So
we'll go through this
together, hopefully let's see.
Can I hide this? Yes,
so this is our folder with the project
and you can see multiple different
files that we will be using like
instructions and so on and
so forth. We'll go through those files later
on to show what they contain.
Here we are activating Python environment because
we are using Python to communicate
back with an agent.
And also here we need to install
requirements as you can see, most of these
requirements are already satisfied because we
run this environment.
Previously,
here I will run the application itself.
I will stop briefly here. The
application itself is basically running Amplify
front end
to to be used as a UI for the cust
for the customer to interact with.
I forgot to mention that the agent core
and the amplifier is running locally.
So it's running locally, it can run anywhere,
of course, but in this case it's running. It
is running locally and as you can see,
basically it is loading the instructions
file. The instruction file contains
prompt engineering for the agent
to understand how to behave
and also, interestingly enough,
we'll see later on,
it contains some additional data about
the sentiment,
basically how to determine
what type of sentiment is customer
producing
the system
itself. I
hate when it doesn't doesn't show
everything, OK.
Let's deploy the front end. Amplify
should jump
into the front end itself.
The front end itself is based on
react,
so that's how it's based. You can of course use
whatever you want in this case,
and this is our front end. It doesn't look super
pretty. It's just
for this purpose that we use it. Our
assistant is called Gus. Of course we
can ask Gus, Hi Gus, how are you?
He will respond
with the information. What can he do for us?
So this is me again as a customer interacting
towards the agent. I'm now giving
him information.
On what I like or what I used to
play, what type of games I used to play.
Uh,
I'm typing slowly.
There is also an on purpose
mistake in spelling,
so it just looks natural,
but Gus is very smart and he will
very easily recognize
what I actually need or what I'm actually
asking. So this is going towards
the database of course in the back end which
we will see different tools that have been
used in the code to help Gus
understand what I'm actually asking because
you will see
in the first in the first run of
this of this iteration,
Gus didn't find anything.
He didn't understand anything, but then.
He reiterated based on some keywords,
based on the tables in the database,
based on
what I was saying in my question,
and he went back,
reran the code,
recreated the query
needed to get that information from the database,
and then gave me some information.
As you can see, there are multiple
different.
Information that he gave me, what I don't
like, I'll just give him some sentiment
that I don't like
Resident Evil because I'm scare easily,
so that's not something that I like. I want
to tell him don't propose anything
that is similar to
Resident Evil. Of course there is another spelling error.
It's not an event, it's Resident Evil.
But again, Gus is very smart in this case
and we very easily understand that error.
So here basically we see what is happening.
My interaction with the
with the with the agent itself.
What I'm asking, he's preparing the
memory of this, you will see at the end,
sentiment analysis enabled.
Interesting thing, this, my first,
my first question doesn't have any sentiments.
I'm just saying, what am I into? I'm in adventure
games.
I like to play this type of game and that's it, so
there is no sentiment related to it.
Sentiment comes when I say
I do not like games or
type of
evil ones or ones which I'm
scared
easily.
So you can see
sentiment neutral,
no sentiment here.
Because there is no, that's my first question.
He will start to run it
interestingly again here by using the
tools
the agent is generating the query
needed to
ask the backend database what I want to show. There
is, there is, you will not see SQL query in the
code. There is no
hard coded SQL query that goes tell us
go do this. There are just instructions
of what I want to
Gus Gus to do.
There is, there is no, there is no
embedded code into the query.
Records found 0,
so you can see created a query select
console journal from the table
and so on.
Records found 0, didn't find anything.
Now he, I'm just calling him
he. I don't know why is it it or he. So
the agent will reiterate,
rerun the code.
Add additional stuff like action
or general like adventure,
and then we'll rerun it and we'll find
150 records this time.
He will rerun it again considering this is maybe
not enough to to
to show.
And he will find some
additional,
additional credits also at the end.
Not there, but the next one.
So you see additional records returned 5.
By not additional but basically
rerun again and
shortening the list.
Now we have
sentiment,
me saying
I'm scared of Resident Evil games,
which is basically now giving sentiment
to the
agent, telling him that this sentiment now
is. Negative or not.
Or bad, I will put it that way. So
he needs next time
to avoid
giving me any results containing
similar, similar games.
If you go into the
code itself, so you can see here, those are
instructions that I mentioned. Within
those instructions are instructions
on how the agent needs to behave,
what the agent needs to do,
how to communicate with me, and
give me back
information that I need
from from the agent
on the bottom itself.
You will see also.
Sentiment when it comes to it, so
Instructions prompt engineering,
classic and on the bottom
sentiment monitoring.
So as you can see, the agent continuously
monitors conversations
and then
decides what type of sentiment is it. Is
it a good sentiment? Is it a bad sentiment?
So I could have thought I could have said
no, this is,
I, I like resent. Give me more of that,
or I don't like as I did, don't give me more
of that in the application file itself,
which is a Python code.
We have lots of tools defined, so we have tools
like tools that will go to the
database and extract information,
tools that help agents generate that
SQL query that will then
bring me back the results.
Also we have.
Other tools that will
Help with the sentiment generation.
So I cannot go through the whole, whole code
itself, unfortunately, it's also very,
very, very small here.
We have different again instructions,
we just saw that.
Let's go to some definitions that
basically define
how the agent responds back to me, and
again, in all of this code, you will
not see any query. There is no SQL query
saying what needs to be done because then it wouldn't
be agent based. It would be just a sequel query
based on some keywords which I provided
in the
in the tour.
Entry point for the agent.
So basically it is based on invocation
totally asynchronous as mentioned,
which is the idea. I don't need to be
waiting for something to happen. I need to
happen immediately back and forth.
OK, session
ID, user ID, and so on and
so forth, everything,
of course,
for this to work, LLM is running in
AWS, so you cannot run your LLM
locally as you are currently running this agent
core and
amplify.
So you need to have your credentials. You
need to have
access to your to your back end where your database
will be and the agent agent logic
or LLM
that you're actually
questioning sentiment.
So you can see it it can analyze sentiment, it
always analyzes sentiment as you
enter something and interact with the, with
the agent itself.
We can go to definitions,
how to analyze.
So how to analyze sentiment and how to output
back to, to event,
Event bridge. Once you have this in EventBridge,
you can then do whatever you want, basically, but in this
case, we are just providing feedback back
to the customer,
how, how to, how to create it.
I'm so sorry this is like silent session and
this is my first time doing it. I used, I used to have interaction,
people asking questions, so
it's weird having you like aliens
with those
red ones.
Yeah, cool, so.
Yeah, so
code basically pattern code that that helps
out in this interaction and defining
how, how all this in the back end works.
Again, the most important, the most important
thing is to understand this is the
event bridge part
where we basically send all that information,
sentiment, confidence, summary
back to the user to, to
understand that part.
I OK,
so I will stop here, here for a second,
uh.
The second, the second part basically
as explained
is
So this is the first part. What can you do with this? So
there are so many agents that of course are
pre-built, or you can just reuse them and
so on. This one is interesting because it's very
easy to deploy.
You can run it, test it locally, and then push it
to AWS and run it in in
in in there if you, if you wish. So this
is just a
concept that proves the concept of.
Basically,
asynchronous communication between the customer
and the agent in the back end and reusing
existing LLMs to provide
additional, additional data. This is like super
easy code is super short, it's not, it's not long,
and it can be very easily tested.
And this is like with user interaction.
When I'm prompting
questions and asking give me this, give me that, and
so on and so forth, and this is all based of course on
your existing knowledge that you possess
in the back end of the database of
all the games that you that you have.
Second part
includes a bit more components, and second
part is, I would say,
not as interactive,
because the idea is that we have a
permanent watcher
or alert-based system.
This time it is through cloud Watch
where we are basically generating an alert
and then
sending that alert through Wet Bridge to
Asian Corp
which then decides the sentiment of that alert
and then does some action and this is
something that is
totally autonomous versus the first one where I
need to input something,
ask back and forth, and interact. Here
we do have
the alert itself, as
you can see, the alert was set up in
this case, maybe not for production, but like.
Every one event with one data point
then raise the alert,
and then I have a rule in the event
bridge basically that is
watching for those alerts, any change of state
and it has a target of
uh, Agent agent
Corps
to do something with that alert. So
we'll see later on what that agent
Corps actually actually does.
So the important thing is
that I'm not just sending him him
again or it. I'm not just sending
it, oh, there is an alert.
I'm sending him, OK, there is an alert.
You need to go back
to the
cloud watch logs. You need to
pick up some.
Information. Additional information
about that alert and you will see later in the code
we have again additional tools
that do that and then do something with the coup.
So this is
Agent Bedrock. I will stop quickly just here
because Jeff also mentioned some of
these. We are using Agent runtime
in this case,
but there are additional options that you do like
built-in tools. Gateways.
We did some upgrades recently on gateways
in this tool.
Memory also mentioned identity is super
important and we will see later on observability
also super important
for this because you don't want this running wild,
not knowing what is actually happening, how many
locations do you have,
how many times your lambda fired because something
happened. You want to fine tune it
either because of the resource usage, cost usage.
Or just optimization of the of the code.
So we are currently using here
uh agent run time for this for this particular
uh agent core.
So again, alert.
I have a fake lambda you will see later that will
trigger a couple of alerts
uh again, nothing to use in production just for demo
purposes.
That will go to EventBridge. EventBridge will send
that to Agent Core.
Agent Core has instructions.
You will see again instructions files, a bit different
one, and this one is not called Gs, it
has a much more ominous name,
but it will then look, oh, there is an
alert. Let me go back to cloudwatch. Let
me collect some additional information.
Let me determine the sentiment.
And let me then decide what to do with
that information.
So what this is doing is actually
relieving our engineers that they don't
have to be there for each and every event,
but they can basically just get the top
level, highest priority events and then
act on them.
OK, so this is the dive. Maybe one
thing to notice here
is just it's a version 7.
I have run this multiple times, so
once we come to the end and and run it
again, so when we go through all the files,
it will be agent version 9, I think,
because we have run it multiple times. So there is
versioning, of course,
within, within the agent.
We can see the invocation code itself.
In this case, Python
blurs some things which contain sensitive
information. So
it's very, very, very simple,
very simple code.
Multiple versions, currently 7.
Once we run it
actually again it will be 9.
Additional information is about endpoint
itself. You can add tags if you want, of course,
when it was created, status ready and so on and so
forth. OK,
this part is super important observability.
This is the thing.
That you definitely want to have, you want to
want to be able to have insights
into the
processes, what is actually happening
inside.
You can of course change the range
when something is happening.
Here I'm changing it for I think 4 weeks
because I run it for 4 weeks
before you see how many endpoints, how
many sessions, traces,
error rates, and so on.
So to see this information,
session invocations, invocations,
and so on, so you need to enable this
in Bedrock.
So there is a checkbox basically
or switch
that you turn on
that then enables invocations
and then
inside we'll just go now into into
that part
into bedrock
where you can see basically.
What types of invocations you want to log
and where do you want to store
that information.
So going to Amazon bedrock.
In my case, it will be turned on because I already
turned it on.
So settings and then here,
let me stop quickly.
Did I stop?
No, I did not hear, stopped.
So, This needs to
be turned on, model invocation logging. If you don't
have that turned on, you will not see that data over
there, which is not good. You, you want to have
that data.
What type
do you want to include into log?
I included all text, image, embedded video.
Where do you want to store that S3 cloud
watch logs only. I will just store
it in a, in a cloud watch
log
uh in this iteration.
OK, let's go to cloud watch the
cloud front to see what was deployed.
So to see what was deployed, there were multiple,
multiple resources deployed through cloud
Front for this.
I will stop quickly.
When it loads
OK.
So Let me hide
this. I hate how it doesn't hide.
Come on
OK,
forget it. So we have lambda event
bridge agent core. So that's
when it comes to
event bridge, event bridge invokes lambda
that then talks to agent core
in talks and tells him, OK,
there is an event, investigate
lambda error generator, that's the fake, uh,
generator for
uh errors where I will click several times just
to generate some errors.
Error alarm itself, agent
SNS topic which will be used to
send an email to
engineer in case the severity
or sentiment of the
error is
high. And then we have uh
The role SAE itself and some and some metadata
on the bottom.
So and all of these have
adequate permissions
to access all these services, so you can really scope
the permissions for each of these to
have access only to what it needs to have
access. Now let's go to the project file. It
is similar
to the one that we already saw,
so it's similar to the
projects that we already saw. You see
requirements. You see instructions.
The instructions are of course different.
It's not the same thing. I'm instructing
in this case, I'm instructing the agent
to when it receives an alert, and when it
receives the alert to go back to cloudwatch to
collect additional data about that
alert, and then based on that to decide
what level of sentiment
it is.
Also, I am using
several, I will see several different
tools to get additional
information about the
about the tool and about the alerts, and
those tools are defined in the code itself.
So I want to get log group name, query.
I want to create cloud of hog insights query,
when it started, when it ended, and so on
and so forth.
So and then on the end.
I also tell, you'll see, I also instructed
the agents to retry
to retry at least, at least
2 times.
If it can to do it.
So get more information tool, notify
higher problem tool. So those are all the
tools that an agent use
once it gets
more information and determines the
sentiment of the.
Of the problem itself.
Everything in the instructions file, so better you
do this.
Better results you will have.
Again, some error handling, you should always
have some error handling, it's not the
best or smartest one, but at least it's
there for, for the tool to know
the agent to know what needs to be done.
Again, application, Python application.
This application defines basically
once the agent starts, how it starts,
what tools are available,
and what instructions are there,
and so on and so forth, so it preloads everything
into the into the service.
I've been using for this.
which is basically in the back end
builds container. It deploys Docker
container to ECR, then deploys
agent in it and runs it
runs it through that.
And the tools itself, they are not invoked
immediately, of course,
when the tool is deployed or agent is deployed,
they are invoked after
something happens.
So there are two parts of this, you may say.
The first part is how to
start
the agent, what are the instructions
and what tools are available, and then the
second part,
when something happens, event driven,
as we are talking all day,
then what to do with it, what tools
to use
to construct proper query.
So to collect data from the
logs and then to basically
decide
what level of severity the
issue actually is.
So all of this, we haven't even seen our
engineer yet.
This is
standing in the background of the of the
service,
listening for those alerts.
And then
Triggering when
needed. So these are the tools
that I have mentioned, either tools for sentiments,
tools for generating inquiry.
Tool for getting additional
data on
On the log file
because I just, I cannot decide
sentiment or the agent cannot decide
the sentiment based just on there is
an alert. It needs to go back, collect
the alert, and then basically decide
the sentiment and what will happen, what will
happen next.
So those four, as you can see arguments log
group name, query, start time and.
And time.
Of course, when that happens, it triggers
lambda, which will then
go to the agent and determine next next
possible steps.
ECS service.
Lambda
RDS and so on and so forth. So again,
it can be send a message, it can be
restart service, it can be
run code, it can be whatever, whatever
is needed. The question of course here
is how much automation do you want to give
it?
Do you need to have somebody in the middle like a person
that will go through this and validate if
something is wrong, how much power do you want to give
to these kinds of services while restarting,
rebooting,
changing, modifying, or sending some commands
to to be something done.
So OK, here we are deploying the basically
agent core
from the terminal.
5. It
will generate the Docker container
and and run it.
Use all the instructions.
In the application Python code and
collect all the tools that it needs
to basically
run the agent.
2 lambdas, as I said.
We have one lambda that is like dummy
lambda for generating code. That's the one on the
top lambda arrow generator,
and then the second lambda is basically to
to be as a as a middleman
between the event event bridge and
the Asian core itself, which then defines
again all those tools and how to access
that information.
This is just a simple code generator which
just trigger a couple of codes
once we go back into the console to see how
that gets triggered and and
and the result which.
I'm sorry to say it's not super spectacular,
but it will show you what actually,
what actually happens.
So let's go back,
agent run time.
Let's see what happened as you can see,
version 9, so
there was one version in between which we, which we
didn't see, uh, around it for test purposes.
So this is now version, version 9.
If we go to lambda functions.
You will see those two lambda functions that we are
basically talking about. This one is to communicate
with the
Agent court.
No, this one is to generate event, right?
Yes, test. So
this one will generate click it multiple times.
It will just send some few
fake events.
Expected errors against demo gods,
so we even recorded one.
But it sends, so it
sends to cloud watch,
and you will see a couple of couple of
events in the cloudwatch.
Let's see that part.
OK, so as you can see,
several events generated.
From lambda
In real life, of course this would be
something that happened actually in the production
again. Alarm that
is triggered
changed state.
It says when the state is changed.
Go run, go
into create an event bridge event
and then from there when you are here
we are choosing to send this to Agent
Corps. So that's one of the options where
the Agent Corps with all those instructions
will decide the severity and everything else.
But once in here you basically can do
anything. This is the beauty of Event bridge
from previous options that you that you
had. But here
again I see two events
happening.
Again, back to lambda.
For the other one, the lambda that will actually talk
to Agent Core.
And it has instructions to do what, to
go back to cloud watch.
And look for more information on
the problem.
So again, you will see here
that it has been triggered.
It's a small trigger, but it's there,
so.
You see that this has been triggered.
Let's see the logs itself.
So this is, this is what's happening.
And here, let me stop quickly here.
So here you can see the full,
full log of what's actually
happening.
Lambda errors errors and inside
here you can even see that it's going back
instructing that it's going back to
the cloud watch and basically
saying, OK, I need to collect additional
information on this error
and I need to define
the sentiment of this
of this error.
Again,
there is no query anywhere. There is no secret query.
The query and all the queries are generated on
the fly based on the on the
information provided
from the log.
It is at the end of Jason payload, as you can
see severity high.
So severity was determined to be high
in this case,
so it could be low, medium, high.
Again,
we decide what is low, medium, high.
I mean, we decide what action
happens if low, medium, or high.
In this case, it's high.
So high severity
notification sent. Let me stop here.
So as I said,
not very spectacular result,
but this is what we
went to our uh service
reliability engineer.
This is the email he got. You can make it more prettier.
It doesn't have to go to email. It can go to a
ticketing system with a high priority assigned to somebody
and so on and so forth.
But this is basically the idea. The general idea,
as Jeff explained,
is to actually automate
part of this in a super easy way
with the technologies that basically were
already there for most applications in
event-driven architecture.
We are just adding on top of it
some smarts.
In a way that lets me reuse existing
LLMs but give them on top some
of my own knowledge
from the logs that I'm collecting and then
utilize that
to offload work from our people,
from engineers that need to resolve those
issues, of course, at the end of the benefit of
the customer.
For the for the application.
So I hope
I managed to
Put it a bit closer for all of you to understand
what is the possibility and
how to
Enhance your existing service application that
you don't need to build up everything
from the ground
up. So
Jeff and I will close up now. Thank you.
So,
That's a good game.
Hopefully that demonstrated health by starting
with building your architecture
in an event-based manner using event bridge
and then incorporating
agentic agents into that process
can help you scale to deal with characteristics
that you might have previously thought from your business
and with that we got
Martin, myself, we're happy in what we built
our customers are happy, our engineers happy and
our and our customer assistance happy.
With that, we thank you very much for your time today.
We thank you for coming to reinvent and we're gonna be hanging
around a little bit longer if you have any questions
for us. Thank you very much.